hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another rendition of Raiders
of the story I was sitting at my desk
about to figure out how to solve world
hunger and cure all unknown diseases
what suddenly this popped in my head
[Music]
will never leave me yes we all remember
the catchy theme song to ducktales even
though we tried God knows how hard not
to but just how well does the show
itself hold up is it as memorable as the
classic tune or will it become quickly
dated like among others let's take a
look at the first few episodes of
ducktales up up up a but if we're gonna
look at the opening we gotta play
different music I still want to keep my
brain attacked by the way if you want a
drinking game they'll have you dead in a
millisecond try taking a shot every time
you come across a clip that wasn't in
the show
[Music]
hey you've been Gosselin from darkwing
duck is really Hughie a drag
so in episode 1 don't give up the ship
we start off this celebration of
American greed with the money bin of
Scrooge McDuck voiced by Wilbur himself
Alan Young and I can only assume that he
made all this money by betting on mr. ed
in the horse races and turning him into
glue he's just like the character from A
Christmas Carol Fagin we see that easily
for meeting up with his nephew Donald
who has to leave his boys behind because
he's off to the Navy yeah you ever
noticed that he's a friggin sailor and
yet in all those years you've never seen
him in the stinking Navy he was in the
army a few times the Boy Scouts even a
fucking Nazi how the hell did that
happen but never in the Navy give this
show credit for finally putting him on a
boat I've never seen a duck so absent
from water so Donald it appears at the
next in the long line of uncles that
keeps abandoning these three parentless
waves yeah how come these boys keep
getting passed around from person to
person I mean where the hell do their
real parents go so Scrooge takes him to
his home or his Butler Duckworth not a
duck spends most of the time looking
after them as you know mr. McDuck put me
in charge of you what today do not get
your knickers in a proverbial twist
you'd have to be wearing pants in order
for that to happen it's expected the set
up it's not a favor for anybody as the
boys keep getting into trouble I told
you until further notice you are
grounded okay I'll take them grounded as
long as there's no bats indubitably sir
how did I let Donald talk me into taking
care of those little beasts
didn't want us what let's leave before
he has any sudden redeeming change of
character those punches remind me of
myself at that age I've been wrong I'm
going to make it up to them in the
morning what the boys notice that
someone is sneaking into Scrooge's vault
it's the Beagle boys so we're trying to
steal a model wooden ship oh what's even
stranger than that is the person they're
stealing it for it's a character named
El Capitan who I can only describe as
McGruff the Crime Dog if he was a
Mexican flashes it leads to a sunken
treasure a ship full of all good by the
way if you can't figure out what he's
chasing in the show yes gold gold gold
Buddhist monks what he was learning this
but it is in code without me to
interpret it for you mental midgets
hey we prefer the toy mental little
people so the boys sneak in and steal
the ship away
[Music]
[Applause]
give me that ship ninos Oh lion tame you
with a bottle of purple drank
they of course escaped and make it to
where Scrooge is conducting a TV
interview at his candy factory where no
comedic possibilities could possibly
occur and how do you explain your
phenomenal wealth mr. McDuck simple I
made it by being smarter than the
Smarties and tougher than the tuppy's I
also embezzled mickey mouse out of house
and home but that's another story but
the nephews crashing as do the beagle
boys to fight over the ship this looks
like a job for an old man with a cane
and three constantly abandoned siblings
now boys
[Music]
puzzle for you so that wraps up the
first episode as we enter episode number
2 wrong way and wrong way we see
Scrooge's rival named Frank heart
Columbian gold look just love these
names as he gets a call from okay Tom Mr
gum good I love those guys boys can you
see him doing something normal like
ordering a pizza that's right and a
large pepperoni and mushrooms the size
of my giant novelty moustache ah and how
will you be paying for that sir good god
that's right I'll be paying with gold of
course 13 is M 1 will be a 8 would be H
and 5 would be e 1 gold I'd mix fruit or
challenge whoever makes the most money
from scratch in in two weeks wins
whoever loses eats my heart deal you
think this is what Bill Gates and Donald
Trump do and there's fair time
acceptance stuff eating is happy eaters
to pay back your swim fins lads will go
on for sunken treasure
[Music]
what they then find out that the plane
they're flying on has been rated as the
pilot appears to be nothing more than a
robot of course eclectic maneuver but
thankfully they have the junior
woodchucks guidebook that shows them how
to fly a plane and for those who don't
know this is the all-knowing plot device
that has the answer for everything like
Penny's book from Inspector Gadget or
Wilson from home improvement or the code
of the less from Cowboys of MU Mason oh
my god you watch that he shut up there's
nothing else on at that time slot Jesus
Christ I'm embarrassed for you
Oh shucks yeah sure go ahead and watch
cowboy cows or cow cows or boy cows are
daddy Timothy do you actually watch that
are you done so they use the book to
figure out how to land the plane it end
up in wrong way where they go hunting
for the treasure do they know that Glenn
Gould is there searching for it too he's
escaped pyjamas distress in the world
doc pajamas
so they come across a cave that
eventually leads to the treasure the
only problem is the water is rising and
they can't go back the way they came by
helping you and your junior woodchuck
seamanship patches they make gold planks
wait a minute they make gold hammers
they make gold freaking sails teaching
these junior woodchucks meetings
children we're going to teach you how to
make a battlecruiser out of this Vegas
but Scout leader why I don't know it's
right here in the bud next to make gold
and planes hammers and sails for an
ancient ship I don't question it I just
teach it but glum golden oak up in Tom
sneak aboard and tried to take over the
ship but end up accidentally sinking it
due to their bickering and since Scrooge
still has one golden coin left from the
treasure he technically wins which means
you know what how do you
it with or without mustard they were
darn good friends from that day on baby
sold his first and then was gone so that
ends episode two as we lead into episode
three three ducks of the Condor we find
out that Scrooge is not the only one to
have that gold coin from the ancient
treasure there's another person who
possesses one and might be able to lead
them to an even bigger treasure which
means the boys will have to be looked
after while Scrooge goes looking for him
this leads to the introduction of mrs.
Beakley and I don't know maybe it's my
inner little boy but I just hate this
fucking character with your precious
little bow and a cutie cute dressed in
those cootie food eyes forever no girls
allowed I'm never gonna like girls till
the day I die
oh shit boobies ruin everything but it
turns out they need a pilot as well
enter Launchpad McQuack hands down
everybody's favorite character don't
worry mr. mcdee if it's got wings I can
crash so the boys are abandoned again
this time not even to a family member
but to the frigging help your uncle has
a three-day pass Wiley ship is in Panama
it turns out Donald has a free pass
because I guess the Navy is very lenient
towards treasure hunting so they bring
him along for the church it's these
freakish mountain winds Thanks
watch
me near
although they crashed into Commodore 64
graphics
get out of there Donald if your loading
time is atrocious okay so after that
lame 8-bit of fact they come across a
tribe that apparently honored something
very unusual actually they're saying
gold son and in keeping with the cartoon
tradition that all natives are stupid
it turns out they honor whoever is
holding the coin so Scrooge finds the
guy who's been using it to control these
people welcome fellow son priest I am
Joaquin slowly is the drummer that one
yeah it wasn't good enough for the
simple
well scooch finds out that the coin was
a family heirloom
Launchpad has a hard time figuring out
how to fix the plane with the natives
y'all are no children of Sonic
you'll fly or bye-bye actually chief I
don't think I can flap my arms fast
enough Jimmy what do you think I am a
duck they chewy make him fly a giant
vulture which he does surprisingly well
so they helped him fix the rest of the
plane meanwhile strewth trades his coin
for half of a map that apparently leads
to an even bigger treasure just before
joaquin turns the tables intruder
[Music]
destroyed but thankfully they escaped
and Joaquin loses his two coins over the
cliff
I command you to get me my coins no son
no son we have to establish new system
of government not coin based so they
drop down all offense fruit is on his
way to find the second half of the map
thus beginning the next episode cold
duck
be very very quiet can bakery del walkie
I don't sue for copyright infringement
haha ready Goodin bucks so in probably
one of the strangest plot points in this
show they use a tuning fork to watch
sorry but how does that work well
there's a tuning fork cause a ground
shaking earthquake every time you use it
when they become law and singing lessons
but the launch pad comes over to collect
some supplies and of course everybody
seems to sneak aboard what are you doing
on this plane so apparently they track
him down to the Antarctic where they
come across an unhappy customer the
writers have confused a walrus for a
bowl a common mistake and also let us
know that Scrooge has been captured by
an army of penguins who also end up
grabbing the boys - hey as long as none
of them are voiced by Martin Short I'm
good
[Music]
whoa nice crotch shot there guys but
don't try to outdo yourself we all know
who has the real money shot around here
adorable
this leaves mrs. Beakley webby and a
girl penguin to try and rescue them and
this is the episode I always remembered
hating because as you'd predict it goes
totally girls show here I didn't know if
you'd like me I don't have any friends
back home that's why I was out on the
ice mom we like you you know you must
you you just gave me all these beautiful
colors wait wait so we have Rainbow
Brite to get a long game at my little
penguin something bear blow up soon so
they dress up webby like a penguin in
order for her to get around easier and
yes this involves covering her face
completely in black makeup
[Music]
sacrifices I make for good taste
they break Scrooge and the others out of
jail by well what else seriously when
did the tuning fork become the fucking
BFG but they're subtly spotted so the
Penguins send their Technodrome igloo
just up but they manage to get out as
well as take the other half of the map
with them the only thing left to do is
drop off their little friend
they can't once kibbles but good you
have to parachute you out no time to
explain how it works just go oh of
course she makes it out fine which leads
us to our final episode in the story arc
too much of a gold thing here the meth
leads them to the quacker echo River a
tributary to the wakka wakka denial
where they land the plane and go looking
for the beach treasure that's been built
up all this time after all the trouble
I've gone through i scrooge mcduck
deserve this treasure
we also get introduced to a sporadic new
plot device known as gold fever
I'm afraid children that mr. McDuck is
in the clutches of gold fever
it's when you itch for wealth so much
you've must get what's important
Oh wasn't that sort of his character the
whole time I mean are they really just
noticing now that Scrooge is greedy you
think it's just a turn to but nope
apparently it's a real friggin disease
in this world it's the symptom of gold
fever the great fever is getting worse
yes webby it was gold fever wave really
hammered this thing in don't they
there's stages symptoms fatal outcomes
this is a heavy-duty shit but for
something so apparently deadly it's also
so incredibly vague couldn't give more
detail for something so fatal I mean can
somebody in an under 2 minute cameo
explain how Gold Fever really works
well you see critic there are several
symptoms of gold fever yes as a research
has clearly shown yes Percy developed
this uncontrollable niche and the loss
of logic on cartoony circles around the
uncontrollable urge to try the need to
lick cows in prom dresses
Oh the bowel bashing tired we hug thirst
for giraffe urine the ability to say the
word applesauce accompanied by 40 dates
of projectile vomiting and then followed
by a sexual fixation for Maggie Smith
but last but not least herpes wait thank
you doctors but so much more light oh so
they make it to the temple with all the
gold but it turns out that if all the
doors are open the temple will entrap
them they're for it you know what is it
with lost civilizations that want to
kill everybody whenever someone finds
their shit they're already dead what are
they gonna use it for but then suddenly
they come across oh yeah survey says
that's what
[Music]
this is a good son but this Cruz goes
crazy with gold fever so this el Kebir
[Music]
taki to one's d'accord at the bottom of
the tent
[Music]
well this scene is incredible
there's a totally overplay this in the
opening credits so much pair comes to
save them and the city is buried forever
doesn't stop from even about just
getting a job four hundred years he's
never looked for a job so as the team
flies away we see that old habits really
do die hard I ahead there where gold
doubloons off the coast the gym did you
see boom
[Music]
several people almost died because of
your greed yeah so that's the duck tale
story art does it still hold up well not
only does it hold up but actually it
really holds up and yeah the story can
get silly of course but for what it is
it does its job really really well
the adventures are creative the
characters are memorable the animations
really top-notch and even the writing
actually can get a few laughs
particularly when it's poking fun of
Scrooge's cheapness in today's world
there probably be a lot more pop
cultural references and modern spins so
it's nice to see a show that can be
really good and not necessarily rely on
that it was both timeless and
entertaining and as nostalgic shows go
it's safe to say that duck tales is pure
ago I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
[Music]
behind you there stranger to find you